in this video we'll talk about the
peripheral tolerance this is a high
topic for USMLE part 1.
imagine the situation when your immune
cell attacks your own body instead of
protecting it and this kind of scenario
leads to autoimmune disorder but thanks
to our tolerance mechanism
immune tolerance work like a safeguard
mechanism to prevent this kind of Auto
reactive cells and thereby protecting
our body
but sometimes this tolerance mechanism
also go wrong in autoimmune disorders
that's why understanding these tolerance
mechanism is crucial there are two broad
kind of Tolerance mechanism when it
comes to immune system and this is
subdivided into Central tolerance and
peripheral tolerance for both T cell and
b-cell there are Central and peripheral
tolerances in this video we are going to
focus more on the peripheral tolerance
now just let's talk about the T cells
and try to understand what happens
during Central tolerance
Central tolerance occurs in the thymus
in the thymus due to negative selection
the autoreactive T cells would
eventually die any T cell in the thymus
which recognize the MHC with very high
Affinity eventually receives a death
signal
and they are eliminated via the
mechanism of self-tolerance
but some of the cases in rare occasion
these cell can evade the central
tolerance mechanism
and that is why there is a backup
mechanism or a second double check
mechanism known as peripheral tolerance
in peripheral tolerance one of the key
player is regulatory T Cell which can
suppress this kind of autoreactive T
cells also there are mechanisms known as
clonal energy and peripheral deletion
which helps in elimination of these
autoreactive cells and protecting our
body from the harmful effect of Auto
antibodies or Auto reactive cell types
so when self-reactive T cells escape the
periphery peripheral tolerance ensure
they are deleted
so peripheral tolerance it's like a
checkpoint you can imagine this entire
tolerance system as a two-way password
checking system that you have faced in
your Gmail account Maybe
so first of all
there are t regulatory cells that sense
inhibitory cytokines such as il-10 TGF
beta and that is recognized by the
autoreactive T cells and they become
less active second there is also
cytokine deprivation that means
deregulatory cell also have il2
receptors and il2 is important for the
proliferation of any kind of activated T
cells so it's kind of like they eat the
food of the autoreactive T cells and
thereby
they are ultimately leading to
inactivation of these T cells there are
a bunch of negative co-stimulatory
receptors such as ctla4 lag 3 on the T
regulatory cells which can modulate the
response of antigen presenting cell as
well
and it can inhibit the antigen
presenting cell thereby indirectly
preventing the autoreactive T Cell
Activation
lastly T regulatory cell can also
secrete perforin and granzyme which can
trigger the apoptosis of autoreactive T
cells all these thing ensures Auto
reactive T cells does not sustain in the
periphery or in the circulation
now the key important part is clonal
energy what really happens due to
autoreactive T cell and APC interactions
there are many negative core stimulatory
signals such as ctla4 pd1 all of these
receptors lead to an energy of these T
cells clonal means only particular cell
type among a subpopulation of T cells
would be affected in this case you can
see only few of the T cells of a
particular or specific against a
particular antigen is affected
that simply means when these clone of T
cells would be further or would be
further stimulated by a dendritic cell
or any antigen presenting cell the
likelihood of activation is very low so
activation probability would be low
eventually energy related genes would be
upregulated which make them more
unresponsive towards any kind of
stimulation
so they are not dead but they are
totally docile and inactive
point to be noted that the energy
mechanism is very selective only one
subpopulation of T cells would be
affected and this is very antigen
specific another particular C4 positive
T cells which is specific for another
different antigen may be a foreign
antigen is not affected by this
mechanism and that brings out the
selectivity of energy mechanism as well
now when these cells does not uh get
enough amount of co-stimulatory signal
and it doesn't get enough amount of il2
mediated induction the auto reactive T
cell would eventually upregulated
uh Pro apoptotic genes and down regulate
anti-apoptotic genes so the balance
between Pro and anti-apoptotic Factor
would be altered in these cells which
would eventually lead to a destruction
via apoptosis it's also possible that
perforin grenzyme mediated pathway and
fast ligand and fast-mediated pathway
can trigger the apoptosis response all
these things are still a active site of
discussion
now what happens to the B cell B cell
generally gets activated by T cells so
there are two important interactions TCR
mhc2 interactions and cd40 and cd40
ligand interaction that triggers the
b-cell activation
so if you want to learn more about
b-cell activation click on the link
above
so once the B cell is activated they
would expand clonally and grow in grow
and proliferate in number eventually
these activated T Cell B cells would
undergo processes like Affinity
maturation and class switching this
would lead to the production or
differentiation of plasma cells which
would secrete a specific subtype or
isotype of antibody
now in case of
peripheral tolerance since the T cells
are somehow inactivated by various
mechanism so T Cell cannot provide
strong signals for the B Cell Activation
because T cell is already allergic or
maybe they died or maybe they are not
they have received negative signals
so once the T cell mediated stimulation
cannot happen for the B cell b-cell is
not really activated differentiation
doesn't happen antibody production is
not happening that means this kind of
mechanism prevents Auto antibody
generation and thereby safeguarding our
body from the harmful effect of Auto
antibodies but in many many diseases
this kind of peripheral tolerance
mechanism goes wrong and that increases
the chance of autoimmune disorders in
different videos we'll talk about
autoimmune disorders
but let me tell you just like T cells
b-cell can also undergo energy or
apoptosis and this is how overall
peripheral tolerance work there could be
energy there could be apoptosis and
there could be negative stimulation
I hope this was useful if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe
follow us on Instagram or Facebook link
is provided in the description you can
support our Channel using super tanks
you can pay via paytm PayPal or UPI
support us on patreon see you in next
video